[Music]
how's my acting good you're on your way
I want to tell you my secret now okay I
see a dead person who you you moron
you'd be Kairos ah can we
go eat
I'm Jeff Ross
they call me the roastmaster general I'm
somewhere in New Jersey shooting promos
for the Bruce Willis roast with
Bruce Willis we are on our way we are
right down the highway and it's like a
place we would shoot a Bruce Willis
movie anyway I think he was already here
in the air-conditioning ducts and he
just dropped down for the movie shoot
[Music]
thank you
okay you guys ready with Bruce I feel
like this is a legacy award almost like
a Lifetime Achievement Award the guys
made more movies than most people could
even see in their lifetime
he is a legend he still looks great and
he's still working so the idea that I'm
getting the roast him is pretty cool for
me because he's a great actor he's one
of my favorite actors Bruce is there
anything you don't want us to make fun
of no it's gonna be like you at a buffet
nothing's off limits limits all right
we're doing a lot of fun setups one is a
parody of one of my favorite films The
Sixth Sense what is a little that's a
little feminine and nothing against
anyone feminine here
I'm sorry why don't you do it twins
reboot with me because you can play both
twins by yourself
I think that is a compliment
it was surreal him coming into my world
we've sort of did a roast battle look at
us buddy
to his credit Bruce took the jokes very
well better than I did I almost cried I
look like you if you died in die hard
now we it's not that kind of roast dude
what